j'ai remarqué une chose c'est que quand
je vous fais des vidéos qui parle de bio
salaire de vous intéresser vachement
moins que la physique fondamentale et
pourtant je vais quand même continuer la
technique dont je vais vous parler
aujourd'hui elle porte un nom un petit
peu barbare elle s'appelle christopher
kas 9
et pourtant je suis sûr que quand vous
aurez fini de regarder cette vidéo vous
serez content d'en avoir entendu parler
parce qu'il s'agit d'une technique qui
va très certainement révolutionner la
génétique
[Musique]
ces derniers temps on entend assez
régulièrement parler de l'idée de faire
des manipulations génétiques que ça soit
pour faire des ogm
j'ai bien faire de la thérapie génique
et pourtant à les modifier le génome
d'une plante d'un animal ou à plus forte
raison d'un être humain c'est quand même
pas si simple que ça alors ajouter un
gène nouveau à un organisme
c'est quelque chose qu'on arrive parfois
à faire al'inverse atténuer un gène est
bien dans certaines circonstances on
peut le faire aussi mais ce qui est
particulièrement difficile c'est d'aller
directement modifier un gène dans l'adn
en tout cas c'est un petit peu plus
compliqué que d'aller corriger des
fautes avec un traitement de texte
enfin ça c'était avant puisque avec
chrysler la technique dont je vais vous
parler aujourd'hui vous allez voir que
allait modifier un gène directement dans
l'adn
c'est devenu presque aussi facile que
d'utiliser un traitement de texte enfin
presque
comme souvent en sciences tout ça a
commencé d'une manière un peu fortuite
est assez éloigné de ce qu'on allait en
faire à la fin alors il ya une trentaine
d'années il ya des chercheurs japonais
qui ont découvert dans le génome d'une
bactérie des petites séquences répétées
qui sont des palindromes vous savez un
palindrome c'est un mot qui peut se lire
dans les deux sens comme bob ou rotor ou
encore ressasser alors d'accord mais un
palindrome l'adn ça veut dire quoi
pour comprendre il faut commencer par
rappeler ce que c'est que l'adn l'adn
c'est une longue molécule qui est formé
de briques élémentaires qu'on appelle
les bases qu'il y a quatre bases
possibles et on les désigne par les
lettres à t g et c est donc votre génome
montez et noom le génome du concombre
que je mangeais de thaler tous ça se
résume à une longue suite de lettres
parmi ces quatre est ce qu ont marqué
nos chercheurs japonais en 1987 c'est
que dans le génome de certaines
bactéries on trouvait des séquences d
adn en palindrome donc c'était des
séquences qui faisait à peu près une
trentaine de base et entre ces séquences
où on avait des séquences normal qui
faisait à peu près la même taille et ce
sont ces petites séquences palindrome
qu'on a plus tard appelé crise peur pour
cluster regularly interstate short par
un johnny klebitz à l'époque ces
chercheurs il avait absolument aucune
idée de ce à quoi servaient ces
palindrome est en fait les choses en
sont restées là pendant à peu près une
vingtaine d'années jusqu'à ce que
quelqu'un découvre que l'important dans
l'histoire s'était pas les palindromes
c'était ce qu'il y avait entre les
palindromes parce que ces séquences
intermédiaires elles sont en fait
exactement identique à de l'adn
virus oui c'est ça de l'adn de virus au
milieu de l'adn des bactéries alors vous
vous demandez peut-être pourquoi des
bactéries posséderait de l'adn d'un
virus et bien c'est pour se défendre
contre lui vous savez les virus c'est
encore plus petit que les bactéries et
donc certains virus
ils sont susceptibles d'infecter les
bactéries de la même manière qu'ils nous
un fake tenait d'ailleurs il ya toute
une classe de virus qu'on appelle des
bactériophages et ils ont une forme que
personnellement je trouve absolument
incroyable on croirait qu'ils sont
sortis d'un film de science fiction
genre la guerre des mondes plat par
exemple on voit des bactériophages en
train d'affecter une bactérie est donc
comment font les bactéries pour se
défendre contre ces virus
eh ben il essaye de conserver un petit
bout de leur adn ce qui leur permet de
les identifier et de les détruire si
jamais il se repointe je vous avais
c'est un petit peu analogue au principe
de la vaccination pour certaines
maladies notre organisme à une forme de
mémoire et le fait d'avoir déjà été
exposé une fois permettent de se
défendre par la suite
c'est dans ces séquences mystérieuse qui
se trouve entre les palindromes c'est ça
la mémoire des bactéries c'est un petit
peu comme si les bactéries gardait une
photo de leur agresseur pour être
capable de l'identifier par la suite
finalement c'est petit bouddha dm c'est
un petit peu le principe de la fiche on
recherche mort ou vif
notez d'ailleurs que c'est un mécanisme
qui est vachement plus efficace que
notre vaccination puisque le fait qu'il
soit dans l'adn fait qu'il est
héréditaire et il se transmet de
génération en génération
moi le fait que mon père se soient fait
vacciner contre la tuberculose quand il
était jeune ça ne me donne pas son
immunité est chargé de me re faire
vacciner alors que ces bactéries qui ont
stocké de l'adn de virus dans leur
propre adn et ben elles vont passer
cette mémoire à toute leur descendance
[Musique]
je vous ai dit que ces petits morceaux
d'adr de virus que les bactéries stocks
il joue un petit peu le rôle des
affiches on recherche mort ou vif tout
ça c'est très bien mais pour que le
système fonctionne il faut l'équivalent
du chasseur de primes vous savez celui
qui va regarder la fiche
et puis tu es ensuite va aller trouver
le méchant pour le but est assez les
chasseurs de primes dans le cas des
bactéries ce sont des enzymes qu'on
appelle casse ces enzymes elles sont
capables d'aller retrouver de l'adn de
virus et de le découper
pour le neutraliser mais pour comprendre
vraiment comment ça se passe il faut
aller un petit peu dans les détails
une chose que vous savez peut-être c'est
que l'adn il est en général pas utilisé
tel quel à nos cellules
elle fabrique d'abord un intermédiaire
qu'on appelle la rn qui est une molécule
à un seul brin qui est complémentaire de
l'adn et qui contient essentiellement la
même information et donc la fabrication
de la rn à partir de l'adn c'est l'étape
en appel la transcription
voilà comment marche le mécanisme de
défense quand une bactérie elle subit
une agression elle se met à faire la
transcription de toute la partie de
l'adn dans lequel il ya les palindromes
et les petits morceaux d'adn de virus
les petit bouddha est reine qui
correspondent aux séquences
intermédiaires ils sont donnés aux
protéines casse et les protéines casse
les utilise en quelque sorte comme photo
d'identification et ses protéines casser
ensuite elle se balade dans la bactérie
et si elle trouve un bouddha des haines
qui colle avec leur arn c'est qu' il
appartient à un virus et donc elle s'y
accrochent et le décompte est donc vous
voyez qu au total ces bactéries elles
possèdent un système qui est absolument
géniale qui leur permet d'aller
identifier des petits bouts ciblé d'adé
n est d'aller les découper
donc ça c'est la nature qui nous le
donne et c'est là qu'intervient l'idée
géniale celle d'utiliser ce système pour
aller faire de la chirurgie du génome la
mise en place de cette idée elle est due
essentiellement à deux femmes
scientifiques
une américaine jennifer yu na est une
française emmanuelle charpentier luna
charpentier elles ont travaillé ensemble
avec une enzyme classe particulière
qu'on appelle la casse 9 et elles ont
montré que cette enzyme on pouvait la
programmer pour qu'elle aille découper
des petit bouddha dn de manière ciblée
et sa pas seulement avec de l'adn de
virus alors imaginons qu'on repère un
gène dans une cellule et qu'on a envie
d'aller le découper eh bien il suffit de
refiler la rn correspondant à une enzyme
casse 9 d'injecter tout ça dans la
cellule et cazeneuve a trouvé la cible
et la découpe et comme si la croyait
russie casse 9 c en gros l'équivalent de
rechercher et coupé vous savez contrôle
f contrôle x alors recherché qpc bien
mais ce qui serait encore mieux ce
serait de pouvoir faire rechercher
remplacer c'est d'être capable d'aller
cibler une séquence données de l'adn de
l'enlever et de la remplacer par quelque
chose d'autre et sadoun charpentier ont
montré qu'en fait ça marchait assez
facilement parce qu'il existe dans les
cellules un mécanisme de réparation
qu'on appelle la recombinaison homologue
qui fait que si jamais il ya un morceau
d'aden qui et endommager les cellules
vont en permanence essayez de le
restaurer et le petit miracle c'est que
imaginons que vous vouliez couper un
gène et le remplacer par une variante de
ce gène donc vous programmez casse neuf
pour faire la découpe et ensuite vous
injecter dans le coin le nouveau gène
que vous voulez faire et grâce au
mécanisme de recombinaison homologue
c'est votre nouveau gène qui va être
pris et utilisé pour faire la réparation
est donc vous aurez remplacer un gène
dans l'adn grâce à 4,9 et aux mécanismes
de la recombinaison homologue vous aurez
pu faire rechercher remplacer dans de
l'adn c'est pas génial ça
alors en fait en soi c'est pas
complètement nouveau il existait déjà
des techniques qui permet de faire ça
mais ça coûtait très cher et c'était
très très long parce qu'il fallait
design est une protéine spécifique
suivant le gène que vous voulez
remplacer ce qui est magique avec kas
neuf c'est que vous utilisez une seule
protéine est simplement vous l'a
programmé différemment avec un petit
bouddha et rennes qui va bien alors il
faut évidemment des techniques de
microbiologie pour faire ça mais pour
vous donner une idée de à quel point
c'est simple si vous savez quelle
séquence l'adn voulait cibler et bien il
existe une boîte qui va vous fournir le
petit bouddha et rennes correspondant en
quelques jours pour seulement 65 dollars
évidemment la découverte et la mise au
point de cette technique ça a fait
l'effet d'une bombe en biologie et tout
le monde s'est mis à l'appliquer a à peu
près tout et n'importe quoi à des
bactéries bien sûr mais aussi à des
levures à des verts à des poissons à des
souris et bien sûr au bout d'un moment à
des cellules humaines
et ça marche partout
[Musique]
chris peur ou plutôt l'enzyme casse neuf
c'est donc la possibilité d'aller
modifier à volonté
n'importe quel morceau de l'adn d'à peu
près n'importe quelle espèce est
évidemment ça ouvre des perspectives
formidables pour la recherche en
biologie et en médecine par exemple on
peut utiliser cette technique pour
savoir à quoi sert un gène
vous savez on a séquencé le génome de
tout un tas d'espèces mais dire qu'on a
séquencé le génome ça veut pas dire
qu'on comprend à quoi servent chacun des
gènes ou au contraire il ya même en fait
qu'une poignée de jeunes qu'on comprend
vraiment et donc grâce à la technique
casse 9
on peut aller modifier ou découper un
gène et regarder ce qui se passe pour
comprendre à quoi servait ce gel
évidemment quand on parle de
manipulation du génome
on pense tout de suite aux ogm alors les
ogm dans nos assiettes c'est vrai que
c'est pas forcément hyper radio temps
mais il faut bien voir qu'il ya d'autres
applications des ogm par exemple
l'insuline que des millions de
diabétiques s'injecte chaque jour elle
est faite à partir d'une bactérie ogm à
qui on a introduit un nouveau gène le
gène de l'insuline humaine pour que ces
bactéries elles produisent de l'insuline
humaine cet exemple là en particulier il
est ancien donc il n'a pas été fait avec
la méthode crise peur et 15 9
mais le fait que cette nouvelle
technique soit facile est disponible ça
ouvre tout un tas d'applications du même
genre par exemple il ya des gens qui
essayent de modifier grâce à 4,9 le
génome de certaines levure pour leur
faire produire des biocarburants
il ya évidemment tout un tas
d'applications pour essaie de produire
des céréales qui résisterait mieux aux
maladies comme le mildiou par exemple et
puis il ya même un projet complètement
fou de gens qui essayent de modifier
l'adn des moustiques pour les rendre
résistant à la malaria
alors la malaria ou le palu 1 c'est la
même chose rappelle que c'est quand même
le plus grosse assassins de la planète
puisqu'ils cause 650 mille morts par an
il faut bien voir qu'un des avantages de
4,9 par rapport aux manipulations
génétiques qu'on pouvait faire avant
c'est que c'est un outil extrêmement
précis on va vraiment juste remplacer ce
qu'on a besoin et donc ça limite
grandement les risques d'avoir des
effets secondaires sur plan
thérapeutique cette technique là elle
suscite aussi pas mal d'espoirs vous
savez peut-être qu'il ya beaucoup de
maladies génétiques qui sont parfois due
au dysfonctionnement d'un seul gène est
donc si on était capable de traiter ce
gène et ben on pourrait guérir les
personnes correspondante
c'est le cas par exemple de la
mucoviscidose qui est causé par la
mutation d'un seul gène qu'on appelle
cftr ou encore de la myopathie et causé
par une mutation du gène dmd
et il y en a plein d'autres la maladie
de huntington la drépanocytose
l'hémophilie et c'est évidemment faire
des modifications génétiques comme ça
chez un adulte ça s'annonce quand même
compliqué parce qu'on
et milliards de cellules de notre corps
et donc on a des milliards de copies
l'adn donc on imagine qu'il faudrait
aller tout les corriger pour
complètement guérir une maladie mais si
on imagine faire une modification du
génome juste après la fécondation au
moment où l'embryon n'est constitué que
d'une seule cellule et ben y'a qu'une
seule copie de l'adn à corriger pour
faire complètement disparaître la
maladie et donc il ya quelques mois il
ya des scientifiques qui ont montré que
c'était possible de faire ça sur un
singes macaques
ils ont fait une fécondation in vitro
ensuite grâce à 4,9 ils sont allés
modifier l'adn de l'embryon et ensuite
ils ont réimplanter l'embryon dans une
mère porteuse et la mère porteuse a
finalement donné naissance à un animal
viable dont l'adn avait été modifié
évidemment je pense que vous voyez où je
veux en venir
si on est capable d'aller modifié
individuellement des cellules d'un
embryon pour trafiquer leur adn
eh ben ça ouvre la voie à de l'organisme
et récemment il ya un groupe de
recherche de l'université sun yat sen en
chine qui a franchi ce que certains
considèrent comme la ligne rouge
puisqu'ils l'ont été grâce à 4,9 faire
de la modification de l'adn d'embryons
humains
il faut bien noter qu'ils ont fait ça en
utilisant des embryons qui de toutes
façons on n'était pas viable et qu'ils
ont fait ça à priori pour la bonne cause
puisque c'était pour montrer qu'on
pouvait guérir chez ces embryons une
maladie qu'on appelle la thalassémie
mais quand même pour la première fois on
a fait de la manipulation génétique de
l'adn d'un embryon humain et donc même
si ça suscite des espoirs et ben ça fait
quand même un peu froid dans le dos je
pense que vous comprenez maintenant
pourquoi je tenais absolument à vous
parler de crise peur et casnav parce que
c'est une technique qui s'est développée
vraiment une vitesse fulgurante en
quelques années et elle permet de faire
des choses qu'on pensait totalement
inaccessible avant et donc il va falloir
qu'il y ait de sérieux débats
bioéthiques qui ait lieu pour décider
quels sont les usages acceptable de
cette technique sur l'être humain et à
la vitesse à laquelle vont les choses à
mon avis il faudrait mieux pas trop
tarder pour que ce débat ait lieu
merci d'avoir suivi cette vidéo même si
c'était de la bio si elle vous a plu
n'hésitez pas à la partager
comme d'habitude vous pouvez vous
abonner à la chaîne me retrouver sur les
réseaux sociaux facebook twitter
ceux qui le souhaitent peuvent nous
soutenir sur tipi un grand merci à paul
et ipr et vous pouvez aussi me retrouver
sur mon blog s'appelle science étonnante
merci à bientôt
[Musique]
à